How do you stay focused?
I stay focused, very easily.
I'm completely, utterly, 100 percent driven by gratitude.
I'm extremely aware of where I was born, and you guys,
I was born in the most communist country-- at its height-- and I was the most capitalistic kid ever born, right?
I had no chance of leaving the Soviet Union-- nobody did, in all those years.
Nobody left Russia, guys. What happened was, there was this singular little moment, where Russia had a food problem,
because they made a lot of bad decisions-- overall, they did-- and they traded Russian-born Jews, to America and Israel--
they made a pact-- where America traded wheat for Jews.
I was traded for wheat and was able to get out of the Soviet Union in 1978.
Insane. So I'm very grateful; I'm very grateful for the fact that I have incredible parents,
I've got very fortunate DNA-- I suck at 99 percent of things in the world.
I just happen to be good at one of the things that really matters, which is how to make money, right?
It's a good thing to be good at, right?
I mean it, I really, really struggle in almost everything, but I'm a good businessman, I'm an entrepreneur.
it's a good-- it's one of the good things to have, for sure.
And so, I'm just driven by gratitude. I'm super aware that we have only have one life.
You know, from what I know.
And I'm super aware that I was gifted with something that matters, that I can communicate, that I can impact others,
while benefiting myself.
I'm super grateful. It keeps me very laser-focused.
You know? Very laser-focused.
I am fuckin' thankful, man.